初めは優しいね
ありがとうおはようございます肇社長です
朝6時半です
というわけでもう荷物が想像入ってくると
思うんですけれども皆さんパ
を待っておりお祭り好きで服っぽく
大大大大あの僕ですねあのを待つにな
るって大事です
お祭りがだいたいない好きなのは釣りで時
に何がきっかけで売れたらもちろんなん
ですよ屋台屋台がとっても好きでもうあの
やつにが並んでいるだけで正直お祭りは
完結してもいいのでは何かと言われる
ぐらい僕の中では屋台が並んでれば
だいたいもそれはイコールお祭りそれほど
良いお祭りにおけるやつ員の対決とあって
かなり大きいと思っておりまして
今回今回なんともう何度も動画で使って
いると思うんですけどもこちらの裏には何
度見てもわかるんですけど裏には広いん
ですよ私思いましたこんなに広い裏には
このままにしておくともったいない日と
いうわけで今日の動画はこの裏には
全部屋台にしたいと思いますだけでこのに
朝早くからお祭りの野菜の皆さんが来て
くださっております話してこの裏にはどう
なってしまうのでしょうか
ああああああ
こういうのこういうのはなんか
うっ ns ピザをゴソゴソいようと思う
ますen 1にしましょうぜひ宜しくお
願いします
tan
[音楽]
これん
持っていた
[音楽]
埼いい
マジで何
ん
んっ
んん
[音楽]
というわけでたい奴がほど待つますねは
今朝とやっぱりや体育力規模時間かかると
いうか調理する場所を作るからそもそも
時間がかかったみたいなんですけれども水
に
a
はず3冊を右足の筋肉はたりが始まりまし
たいや右安になる価格がマッチってママっ
てるんだマイケルだけどたんだけど今回は
跳ねる車間を右足の筋肉祭り2022冬
並み僕はでいいけど見てないんでマジで
バカねどういうパフォーマンスになって
いるのかトマトみたいですけど早速見て
いきましょうん
[音楽]
バッハ
ちょっと明天これ
道
祭を完全乗りますね
騒々しい都会を離れ
静岡意義の南口から車で約10分
閑静な住宅街に立ち潜むぬ
3億円の家の扉を開けると
その奥には
懐かしいなんだこれ懐かしいといって別に
今も祭あるんで懐かしいわけではないの
ですが懐かしい雰囲気を漂わせるお祭りの
景色がキロがっていました
肇社長の昔あそびにいった夏祭りの記憶が
興味が彫ってきましたーー
ん小沢せみようかな
小沢しまった
[音楽]
俺にバイオ連中が二重ずまず最初に出る
ような広島焼きですよ
きちゃったね結構見るようにを待ってるで
みますねねぇ
遺影を前地区の裏ティアでいらっしゃい
ますよすいませんがとなりございません
あっじゃあ一ついただけると熱い
明けんすけどでも加須山 t こっちは
ちょチャージマヨネーズはお付けしますお
願いしますはい割り箸もありますので
ハイレゾへ待っていただきますはい
ありがとうございますループうーん
ちょっと触ったさん
[拍手]
はっはっは終わってるきているということ
だながいただけます
なんかさ檻さああんまり自慢話三代になっ
ても嫌なんですけど
10名になってからということは u 2
バーでそこそこ名が売れてからさんを待つ
いけなくなったっていう大学の時一家いい
彼女を連れて山お祭りたんだけど盗撮され
すぎて
5切れちゃってエアーチャックが悪くなっ
たっていう苦い思い出がある行こう
行かなくなっちゃった確かにねそれ誰って
ちょっと有名になるとね
かわいそうによく聞くす喪服の祭りで
はじめ車場にあった来て本当にチーズが出
たって言ってたけど
日だるだるよこの子
生きたて寄ってきたんでしょ持っただけ
わっ
こんな静かな末やるんだあの bgm 流し
ているんですけどミュージアム止めたら
こんな感じです
なんて bgm があれば飯食ってる
異なりますから全然も楽しいた走った素直
に旨い本当にはいっ
ペット
[音楽]
ブーバーいっきまー
ぬーんっに上の右上のみーにょう判断の約
3つと戻します
マジで入れビーチたがいます
1ターン目でございます
こんにちはー
じゃあでも多くだはいはいた方いますか
[拍手]
[音楽]
あれます
いただきます
一口
運命付いたことだ
カーキーゴールでございますよ若干に冬に
限られることないからなー
なかなかねえ
やっぱりどうぞ夏のイメージがう
次だと危険なそうですそうですねちょっと
枚ストップといいまで青空さん剥ぎ合わせ
ていんだぞっ
[音楽]
あっ引いてクラブで1またゼミ等はダメな
やっぱりやーなっつかしーさしぶりに見た
わけでゴリなっ
甘いは冬でも
で便は言えでも甘い懐かしいあの味だ
あたる存在は大いらっしゃい
恐れ頭が投げですね入ったはずだて月だ
おもちゃ
輪投げ得意よ5回ありますメジロ原型お
願いします一方聞いて言っちゃうの僕は月
見に行きますから
いきます
[音楽]
はいわかりましたよなぁ
バイブ1社たやつ3月ます
普段生む具をシーン
[音楽]
うんで終わるおめでとうございます良い
javari やばいん
ケース径の夜ご飯が岡直やかかってる
キョンマジで絶対法が1口本当に勢いを1
個入れてません
本当に連敗じゃあ先生の夜を張ったら寸
スイス滞在者でですここあ
すごい最善かんですね
あっやばいかもを使用しでしょ
今一番の動画的に見ずらいの取っちゃった
声
パルクハルク
やばいっ
結局休憩を
数ある日君
終了ですそう最後健介撮りたかったらね
ハルクじゃないよねなにこれ復旧いやば
ちょっと俺の知らない屋台だうんなくね
嘘をついたの今日ですね3回なくこう
チャレンジしていただいて赤い丸に入った
個数 marauder 論議となって
まして3つとも赤い所入った方がいいです
ねや事故んじゃろうな奴が多悲しみが吹か
せいただけますかっこよくれごっこエルフ
ピアスもむず
表を
愛 free っていう
oes いい感じです結構笹でのがまず第
一弾あそっかぁ死ね件
ああっ
ああ
[音楽]
歴代弱ものだと弓道着ますから技研投げ
うわーすげー月じゃないですかが地形な
わけですね安全な高
刺され屋大須鯉太郎俺はケース切り投げ連
なぁさすがに目
おしっこ a
実は私こう見えで忍者カフェに入ってた
ことがあります赤埋まりにいくつか刺さる
と語り商品大穴ローなるほどでは行かせて
いただきますお願いします今はい
viber を知っ
[音楽]
ん
ああああああすごい
こんなことはねあと2位9
[音楽]
わー3ターン毎ございまーございます
io 流のおもちゃですねマジですか白を
どうぞやっちゃあ自発通ったらさあそして
を待ってると言ったらこれじゃない
でしょうか
たこ焼きでございます全部打っ
茹でる
上がってくるそうです
聞かれてちゃんとこれねこちらなんで全然
はいあれ者はその中猫背だかターンでき
たってよりこっち図っていけるぞいただけ
ます
[音楽]
んまぁもうまんどとした
何度季節かぁ
弱ったつは楽しんでもらいましょうかの
期待もう
いわば
そしてポップコーンですね家へティ
会う前
うわぁるもうだとお祭りのさーこれって
言えたら頃すると思ううーん満足これで
終わるわけにはいきますね今回もこの
3億円の祖父の管理人がもうすぐ多分家に
来ると思うのでいつも通りを中小都市に
打つに来て貼ってあげた瞬間家の中がお
祭りになっていたらどういうリアクション
するのかさっそく見て行きたいと思います
はしばしお待ちを
うん
[音楽]
そぼろとオタクすぐようですし空
ん
ガーナランダーグランド法案になりもう
ようなんでも何度でも何度で今日は何でも
ない日だからちこ何でもある日でしょいや
た世代が強いのではない強いのではない
痛くないでしょうか雲なら大方がいいな
[音楽]
そのださんどっか連れてかれるかと思う
けど別名とっている背面と踊ってますね
はい言ってまで続いてます愛車が閉じて
ますはい
はいでははいっ
上4杯開いてくださいはいちょっ
えっいい
うわぁ
縁日7ホレス前ねっ
[音楽]
なったこっそりサイズなんだから何
相手が何だろう言いたい lec ですよ
すげーってたこ焼き居るよ
土岐郡もあるんだしさあああ
裏庭がお祭りになってドッキリさあ
よく見たらとか入り口も好きです
欲しくなってやってくるでは香港が作って
大丈夫フェスや前雨具などの罪のためは
本当にむしろ焼き食べての頭痛の日って
感じだって貼りましスカイドン取ってって
くださいありがとうございますありがとう
ございます
ただヤバいネタばいい砲兵あっちっ
あっほんと
何やってんの家に椅子やでも嬉しいな
やっぱりほら今さこの中で松井とかじゃ
ないじゃん屋台とか近くを見てなかった
から
めちゃめちゃテンション上がる
[音楽]
うまえん
お前これだけてこれ懐かしい味というか
この屋台の
感じいいねこれてるん
1分やってほしい屋台がやってほしい屋台
ん
チェック見せてもらおうああ確かに行き
なんだって僕中学の時弓道部で
縁あってましたからですお灸同文使うため
されるよう上がってちゃって
ここはもう様になってるよ
is やアシカもう
oo
今
メッツぽいぞ
[音楽]
の
あっ
[音楽]
はーる
elr